jason kalakanis joins us to talk about
what big tech has been through
over the last couple of weeks welcome
back jason good to see you
good to see you carl where has your head
been
on parlor uh and what's significant
about their return if they can make this
stick
yeah i mean parlor was like the island
of like the misfit
uh children everybody who got kicked off
of twitter
you know found a home there and it was
pretty gnarly i've been on it
since it started and they were doing
very little policing
and people were saying some pretty crazy
um
incendiary stuff on there including
somebody who was pretty high profile
saying
they should take vp pence and uh you
know have him face the firing squad for
treason
and this kind of um inciting of violence
as we saw on january 6th
is no longer you know a theoretical
somebody screaming
fire in a crowded theater i mean people
are dying because
of this dog whistling and my belief is
that
you know some group of law enforcement
uh
folks went to amazon google
apple i don't have definitive proof of
this but that's been the chatter here in
silicon valley and just said hey listen
here's the receipts
do you want to have another january 6th
and do you want to know if you could
have
avoided it and the other
thing that's occurring is the employees
at these companies simply do not
want to go to work knowing that they're
supporting
uh trump's unique brand of chaos and so
it you know trump trump did
uh he gave them an off ramp you know in
the final two weeks of his presidency
he gave not only the gop an off-ramp to
to disconnect from him
he gave twitter and very easy uh youtube
a very easy
exit ramp uh to disengage from him
and cynically they were very the big
social was very much in favor of trump
and the
and the ratings he brought not unlike uh
some people cynically feel about
the media business uh giving him a lot
of air time for ratings
and uh you know similarly two weeks
before
trump's gone uh you know and and
um you know that that would certainly
appease the blue wave that's about to
to hit our shores on wednesday right
so but where does it end jason and are
you worried about as we've moved from
you know uh twitter suspensions to
actual cloud service that this will
bleed into areas that
uh do not reflect a true danger but are
more politically motivated
yeah this is a very interesting question
what i've encouraged my friends to do is
not take
the black swan event of trump and make
policy based on
donald trump's unique brand of of chaos
that he creates in the world it's like
basing things on the joker's behavior in
a batman movie like he did crazy things
that
really stress test not only our
democracy but it also stress test
everything he touched
and you know i if it was me and i was it
was twitter i would have given him a
hundred day suspension and then
you know just to to not give um
you know the right wing you know uh or
the the alt-right
too much um ammunition but these are
private services
and and they have the right to serve who
they want and all of this is going to do
is create a whole nother class
of startups um for us to invest in and
for us to back and the free market will
do its work so there'll be an aws
competitor that says hey we're going to
put our foot down and we're going to
allow
freedom of speech on a level that might
make some people uncomfortable
and so it'll just be a business
opportunity
for some other companies to to service
these folks and
i do think it's kind of a one-time event
and i do think that it was driven by
public safety i don't think this was a
coordinated
we hate trump attack because all these
you know
tim cook was more than happy to go to
meetings with ivanka and and trump for
the last four years i mean he was
you know at the right hand of trump in
every photo op so it
it's obvious that this was more about
public safety than
you know the employees of all these
silicon valley companies hating trunk
jason a couple of follow-ups to what you
just said there
one is it it sounds like you think there
will be a further fragmentation of
social media
not just fragmentation of what people
are seeing and what they're interacting
with
on platforms like facebook and twitter
but of full fragmentation
with people with different political
beliefs just communicating on different
platforms is that right
no no i think this is like a one-time
stress test on the system and that we're
going to go back to
very boring politicians i think people
voted for boring this time with biden
you know who knows in 2024 we might vote
for a very boring republican
um and i think we'll all get along a lot
better
and i really do think this is like our
system a stress test
by a bad actor an insincere person trump
who just stress tested it and i don't
think that there's a need for a parlor i
think
a lot of these folks will you know from
the alt-right were driven from the right
to the alt-right just like some people
on the left were driven
into hysteria over trump uh and got
trump derangement syndrome so
i think the good news for our country is
it's going to be hopefully a very boring
4 eighty years uh out of washington and
we don't have this kind of chaos
um the real challenge was you had
somebody sitting in the presidency
acting you know really erratically and
that is a very hard thing
somebody's got the most important seat
in the world in the free world
and they're behaving in a very
irrational manner
uh and you saw it in the people who
stormed the capital they said
the president told me to do it who could
ever come up with a
test like this it's crazy jason it
certainly
was a very unusual situation and has
been a very unusual situation but i'm
wondering if you think that
the actions we took twitter and facebook
uh
you know take just in the past couple of
weeks in order to shut down the
president's
account do you think that represents a
sea change in terms of how they're
thinking about content on their platform
perhaps in anticipation of changes to
section 230 and changes to make them
more liable
to what for what's shared on their
platforms
yeah i i i think that we're all going to
come to
a pretty basic agreement which is don't
incite violence don't be a racist don't
stalk people you know public safety um
and we'll get back to
uh some reasonable freedom of speech
um uh approach from these platforms i
think we'll keep 2 30
and uh i i think the idea that you can
throw people off the platform has now
been highlighted and that that can be
done in an unfair manner
and i think that'll make the platforms
maybe come up with an obudsman type
approach
like the new york times used to have an
ombudsman who would
comment uh independently on their
reporting i think that
um kind of set up for social media would
be very helpful
if there was a group of people who you
could appeal to if you were
you know removed from uh social media
and they could say hey you know
uh they could arbitrate it and um that
would be a nice solution i think and
i think you'll see some self-regulation
from the twitters and facebooks rather
than
you know putting their foot down in some
way i wonder what is is really going on
here because
there were these talks about amazon
squashing free speech and this
existential threat to paul it's been 10
days since aws
dropped parlor and parlor's coming back
also
is there a business model for loose
content
moderation i mean you talk about the
idea that maybe there's a
an aws or different social networks for
for like loose content moderation isn't
that
kind of an invitation to get your pants
suit off if you're a company and so how
much more capital do you have to raise
and how much more insurance do you have
to have and so therefore how much do you
have to charge
because what advertiser is going to want
to be next to that right uh a hundred
percent
um you you got that you nailed that one
john um
the any regulation we add to these
companies uh reinforces the incumbent's
position because they have the ability
to hire lawyers and moderators
and parlor doesn't right so but i don't
think
most rational people would like to run a
service
where people are inciting violence and
so that's a very unique group of people
who would want to live in that world and
it might be offshore
where it might be some really hardcore
uh
libertarians but what they're gonna find
is not only do
people not want to invest in that
company or own equity in it they're
gonna find people don't wanna work for
that company and if you've been on
parlor it's
it's it's garbage it's a terrible app
it's poorly designed
it's slow you're not going to get
world-class people to even want to
uh be on the platform or to support it
invest in it or build it
and that at the end of the day i think
is is a big part of what happened here
is
jack did not want to come to work and
have his top engineers and his top
lieutenants
leave the company and i think it was
getting to that point where
it was causing so much chaos just like
it did at our thanksgiving tables or
christmas
you know celebrations or zooms you know
we had to deal with internally in our
families fighting
this is what every company was dealing
with with trump's insanity
and thank god everybody voted boring i
am so
excited for 72 hours from now to be able
to focus on work and family and david
defeating the virus
and not have to deal with captain chaos
anymore i think it's going to be
wonderful to
remove this cognitive overhead from all
of our cpu
your broader points good and that is
that companies they are families
and uh and you got to hope that behavior
in general is self-correcting
uh no matter what part of the political
aisle you're on it's great to see you
uh thanks for great to see you stay safe
everybody we'll see you soon better days
our next guest is saying the recent
reddit trade is quote
the messy middle of a revolution early
robin hood investor in inside.com
founder jason calacanis
joins us now jason uh what a story
what an investment for you i'm sure you
say you're off skiing but now you're
back
paying attention to this story now first
there's a conspiracy theory
advanced without evidence by tyler
winklevoss on this show yesterday that
political leaders forced robin hood to
stop the buying yesterday is that what
happened
yeah i i have no information on that and
uh you know good luck with the
winklevoss twins and
trading bitcoin they're they're total
heroes to me so
i'm joking uh i don't know that they
know what they're talking about
so um i would disregard whatever they
say um
but it is certainly an interesting turn
of events and yes that's a blizzard
behind me and
uh this is just actually tipped over
into the consciousness of
everybody i mean on the lift in front of
me
people were talking about should they
buy gamestop i kid you not
and this was like a 15 year old kid and
his parents and they're talking about
gamestop and they're explaining shorts
and i was like you know what this is
actually why i invested in robin hood
this is why robinhood was formed robin
hood and i don't speak for the company i
don't have any inside information i did
not talk to vlad although i did see
the great hit that andrew uh did last
night uh that was good get
congratulations on that
and you know when they pitched me this
idea at antonio's nut house
in palo alto uh before the product was
launched
you know vlad said to me we want to get
millennials to trade stocks
and i said these are the same people who
are totally commitment phobic
they're yolo they they're on their mom
and dad's you know netflix accounts they
don't buy cars they take ubers
um how are you going to get them to do
that like what's the opportunity there
he goes
well what if we do what if we do get
them to trade like what would that look
like
and i said well okay great i like that
idea it's a new market
um and i said you know retail is gone
like there's no retail investors
jason that's the opportunity i said okay
i like the way you're talking great keep
going what's the business model
he said we're gonna let them trade for
free and i said i'm in you know this is
like a great idea obviously that will
get people
i mean this is what my life is like yeah
the same same pitch as uber like we're
gonna you know people gonna give up
their cars and they're gonna use an app
but tell me these crazy ideas work and
jason and i think
yeah go ahead john is this free to trade
model
as we see it now sustainable under these
conditions i mean how much
money is robin hood going to need in
reserve it's going to
have enough to operate when things like
we've seen over the past few days happen
yeah and that that clearly is the issue
here clearly
communication wasn't very good yesterday
i think vlad owned that great
these are growing pains that these big
companies go through facebook went
through 12 of these
uber went through 17 of these and and i
talked to you about every single one of
them
uh sometimes when you have hyper growth
you have these kind of edge cases
and and so they're going to obviously
need to have more money uh on hand
clearly i'm not an expert on these
regulations and what the covenants are
and the coverage needs to be but this is
a great stress test
of our financial system and it's
absolutely awesome
that young people are on wall street
that's getting this financial education
because
the way to accumulate wealth in the
united states is to own equity and
equity participation you cannot win
just being and you can't certainly
change your strata in life
and move up uh into another you know
level
if you don't have equity participation
it's very hard to do that on income
and so it's great that this education is
occurring but the you have to understand
when something hits number one in the
app store
that is a large amount of downloads
so this is as if everybody in the
country decided they're going to go to
las vegas on the same weekend
this is unsustainable it's unsustainable
to onboard all these accounts i am
certain
and it's unsustainable certainly to have
so many people either trading on margin
or doing
you know puts in calls this is
unprecedented and i think they're going
to need to digest it and they're not the
only ones are they like
every single broker is having the same
issue right now there's too much
participation and that participation
will take time to digest and we'll get
on the other side of it i'm sure
jason it's deirdre um you mentioned the
interviews that vlad did
um last night and he said in a number of
them
that robin hood has restricted trading
to protect their customer
who is robin hood's customer yeah i mean
i think
ultimately it's those retail investors
if they lose those retail investors
there is no business
the retail investors jason a customer is
someone who pays robin hood
as you've mentioned a few times retail
investor does not pay robinhood those
are commissioned for trade
the customer is actually wall street
isn't it it's the money
it's the market makers who pay for order
flow
so how can the business model be let
traders trade for free it's actually
making money off of order flow is it not
well of course and they're very upfront
about that now and it's been very clear
but some businesses are based on having
large audiences that trickle i think so
i think
like you said yeah i think they never
talk about that they talk about
democratizing trading
and they talk about commission free
trades all the time we rarely hear them
talk about order flow
i think people understand it i think
it's in all the terms of service and
they've been very clear about it so
you know it's it's very similar to the
facebook situation where
you get a free product if those
consumers don't use facebook the free
product or instagram or twitter the free
product
uh or cnbc the free product uh you know
you don't have the ability then to make
the money
off of that audience if you will and so
okay
that yeah sure go ahead so
a lot there's been a lot of trust lost
in facebook over the last few
years so why should traders trust robin
hood
if they now know that they're turning
around and selling their trades
to market makers and perhaps not
executing
at the best price okay so number one
they've been clear about
with the market makers that that's how
they make money everybody understands
that
the second piece is um should they trust
them
after having turned off trading
yesterday i think they have to rebuild
that trust
so i think that these companies when
they go through crises like these
and every big company whether it's tesla
whether it's facebook whether it's uber
or airbnb when somebody trashes an
apartment these new platforms that get
to scale there's always going to be
these crisis moments
and the way you can judge the founder is
do they communicate well
and i think vlad's doing a better job of
that and i think he did a good job last
night on
bbc i know he'll do a better job
tomorrow and then how do you
ask me the question let me give the
answer please and the answer is
they need to earn that trust every day
by having a stable great product that
delights users
and whether it was uber which took a lot
of hits or facebook and instagram
yes all these platforms have taken hits
they have made mistakes
what i look at as an investor in them is
how do they respond to them do they
learn from them
and do they get stronger
jason what i'm hearing you say basically
i mean i'm
less concerned about robin hood and more
concerned about the broader market yeah
is that this is the biggest cyclical
this is a classic cyclical flow of
retail into the market
and that it will uh ebb out as it always
does i don't hear you talking about
major structural change or some sort of
end of centralized finance as we know
some people have tried to argue on our
air
yeah that's a little silly i think
that's those the crypto folks going down
the crypto rabbit hole and they think
like nobody's going to be in charge of
anything and the entire world is going
to be on some immutable blockchain
that's not controlled by anybody that's
super interesting and a great
intellectual argument it's not very
realistic sometimes you do need to have
central controls and and
bitcoin is a fantastic technology does
not apply to everything
uh so they're a little drunk on the
distributed finance
and all that stuff i know it's real but
you can't apply to everything and what
we what we saw here was
these shorts i mean i think that's the
bigger issue it's easy to gang up on
robin hood or wherever the lead company
is
all due to respect deirdre but and they
and they do have a responsibility as the
lead company
to be the best performing company and i
guarantee you they will be the best
performing company
i've seen this movie before putting that
aside the big issue here is
you know who is shorting this stock how
can you short 130 percent of a company
i still don't have a great answer for
that that makes no no sense
and then if have these shorts all
covered their position
and then if the if people are buying the
stock now at 20 billion or 30 billion or
whatever they want to buy it at
is there any chance that the company can
live up to that and has the company
state changed have they done a secondary
have they put a billion dollars of this
you know incredible acceleration in
their enterprise value
into their coffers and is there some
vision here for how gamestop becomes a
20 billion dollar company i could see
betting on it becoming a five billion
dollar company but
that's what i'm getting concerned about
i'm concerned about that too jason and
yeah something that i've raised this
week is part of the potential it seems
to me
of not just wall street bets but this
whole
surge that we've seen in consumer
interest in finance
is handling some of the nuts and bolts
too i mean
equity investing is great but so is
saving
so is budgeting you know so is getting
those tools and tips together
getting good research together so that
the the individual retail investor
has really deep insight into what's
happening with these stocks
do you think that's going to happen is
that an angel investing
opportunity uh and when how
but it's already happening i mean what
you're seeing right now between
you know is young people who have time
on their hands instead of gambling
instead of going to vegas
instead of going to school and being on
zoom classes and playing video games
they've decided this is a
more interesting video game and you know
what they're learning by doing and that
is the best way to do it
if you don't understand if you want to
learn how to play poker just get in a
poker table and play
the low stakes game but that's what i
worry about don't play high stakes
though
you're saying instead of gambling and i
hope it's instead of gambling
it's harder to do the research versus to
be on a ski lift and talk about should i
buy gainstop it's it's
it's harder to download a pdf you know
and figure out a model for selling that
not just to 50 or 500 people but to 500
000 people how is this movement or maybe
the kinds of silicon valley innovators
who brought us robin hood
how are they going to get us there it's
already happening if you just go to wall
street bets and you start reading some
of these threads as my bestie chamoth
sdc said on the air on wednesday when he
was going on his tirade
um uh on halftime i believe
you know these uh folks are very
sophisticated and they have time on
their hands
and collectively collectively the
internet can produce
amazing things that individuals cannot
one example of that but one example of
that is the wikipedia
there is no paid staff yet they've built
them the biggest corpus
of knowledge in the world ever created
and it's still growing
every day day in and day out they're
always begging me for money though
yeah i know somebody's got to pay for
this stuff right
yeah back to business models so i think
that's what's happening and they're on
discord service talking about it and
it's going to be amazing for society
but what they're also doing is they're
stress testing
all of these crazy hedge fund folks who
short stocks
and then do all the fear uncertainty and
doubt the fud that they did
to to poor tesla betting against tesla
for years
and i had to come on the air here and
say listen it's the greatest car in the
world
the guy landed two rockets at the same
time why are you shorting this stock
it's so stupid
yeah like shorting elon musk is the
stupidest thing you could do
like this is like shorting apple you
know and steve jobs not to say that all
shorting is bad though you know channels
shorted
right enron we had shorts against the
housing bubble sometimes the shorts are
the heroes i got questions about
what happens when we end up in that
situation but jason i think we gotta
leave it there thank you for the time
i'm gonna get out in that blizzard
and hit some runs enjoy those slopes
jason calacanis always great to have you
joining us this morning talk about this
and a lot more as angel investor
inside.com founder and early uber
investor jason calikanis
jason welcome back good to see you as
always good to see you i hope you're
safe carl
yeah we're doing okay um let's take your
time
yeah i think we're hanging in there
valuation all the things we just talked
about for the past 90 seconds
uh how much of it is um a topic of
discussion in your circles and how much
of a concern is it
in your circles yeah i think what we're
seeing is
and i've had this discussion with a lot
of people who are managing money in
pools of capital
and if you look at commercial real
estate it's absolutely been devastated
because people are working from home
so all of that money that would have
went into commercial real estate is now
looking for a home then we look at
residential real estate
nobody wants to live in san francisco it
is becoming a ghost town when i drive
through san francisco
it is like something from a dystopian
science fiction film there is
nobody on the streets stores are closed
and just giant mansions
in pacific heights are empty so
nobody is buying uh residential real
estate
then we look at travel hotels and small
businesses like restaurants
all the money that was put into those
efforts that's looking for a home
so where is somebody going to put their
money well you're not keeping in cash
because they're printing money
like it's tissue paper right now so
money needs a home
money is looking to grow not uh you know
become devalued
what's the safest bet well as far as i'm
concerned
disney google facebook netflix
uber uh tesla square these are companies
that will be here in 10 years
and they're going to thrive because
they're the anti real world portfolio
that's obvious
now we put another layer on top of that
which is
we haven't had retail investors since
1999-2000 and we have a generation of
people
who are on their parents netflix
accounts living in their parents
basements
who now have discovered an app called
robin hood which i was lucky to be one
of the earliest investors in
and right we've got over 10 million
people participating in the market
who by all you know logic
you would think have no interest in the
future at the same time
gambling has gone away so there couldn't
be a more perfect storm for technology
and for people placing those bets and so
then one would naturally answer
you know your next question should be is
this going to end in tears
well i mean my next question is
commercial real estate
and economic urban economic activity
will go down until it stops going down
and at that point
when it when does the mean revert
it i don't believe it's going to i think
what we're having is such a seismic
shift in
people's personal world views due to
work from home
that it will be impossible for an
employer
to get people to come back to offices
and listen i am an
in the office guy i want everybody in
the office you cannot work from home
you want to work from home you take a
sick day we're in the office getting
stuff done we're revving on the product
that's always been my position
and now i lost the war i'm not going to
be able to compete for people unless i
tell them they can work in napa
unless i tell them they can work in lake
tahoe and come see me every month maybe
for a retreat
and people are not going to spend you
know two three four five thousand
dollars a square foot in manhattan
if they could spend three four five
thousand dollars on an acre with
broadband
up in new paltz or albany or hastings on
the hudson or out here in napa
this is a this is a lifetime change
they're not coming back to the offices
carl
uh jason this is john good morning
john good to see you good to see you i
mean facebook
google so many companies spend all this
money
designing these spaces for people
you know having these open cafeterias
you know bringing in contractors making
this wonderful food that became so much
a part of the culture
are they going to be able to completely
dismantle all of that
for a different mode or if the fear goes
away is that going to change so
but but i also want to know from you
specifically because you're such a
prolific
not only angel investor but also part of
that ecosystem
is there enough capital out there to
keep these smaller operations going
during this difficult time or are we
going to see a lot of
small startups shutting down uh
and kind of going into hibernation mode
yes
those are two great questions um i'll
take the the the last one first
so we invested in 75 companies a year
i've invested in 250 startups uh over
the last 11 years
uh in the first two or three you know
uber robin hood thumbtack
and what i see in my portfolio is you
know maybe 20
their revenue went to zero and thank
goodness for the ppp
loans um and you know the
unemployment it's like i i hate trump
with every fiber of my being that he's
the worst human being on the planet
that being said he got that right and
you got to give him credit
for pouring money into the system
because we saved a lot of jobs
then i look at 20 30 of the updates
they get from startups and revenue
doubled tripled
during the pandemic these are the ones
that are used by people with keyboards
or who are staying home and have extra
time and then in the middle there was a
lot of adjusting
all of that's been done small startups
five to 500 people
are nimble and so they are able to shift
on a dime
if you're an airline company if you're a
hotel company if you're a restaurant
you cannot make that shift it's just not
possible now
to the earlier point about these
campuses these campuses were vanity
projects
and they were a way to lure employees to
come work here and
not on wall street to work here and not
in hollywood or somewhere for
you know god forbid one of those like
boston consulting groups or
one of those jobs so we were able to
take all the talent away from wall
street
and those you know jobs where you write
reports that nobody reads
mission accomplished those are going to
be deprecated or they're going to be put
on ice or they're just not going to grow
them
and so they'll just become they'll still
have those campuses for the people who
want to come to offices
but given how expensive things have
gotten
people are really smart and they're
realizing that the work can be done from
anywhere and this was about ten percent
of the market people like wordpress matt
mullenwag
another company called envision they
kept telling us work from home is the
thing work from home is the thing
and i was like nope you're never going
to make a world-class product unless
everybody
is in that office for 60 70 hours a week
and we used to judge startups
based on this was like a little secret
how many cars are in the parking lot on
a saturday sunday vcs used to drive by
hey parking lot full okay facebook
that's a good investment
that's over and you have to compete
against
other companies google is now looking at
the world saying
gosh you know they haven't made a really
big comment on work from
home and they're going to lose their
employees to people like facebook
and that's going to become an
existential risk for them and they will
fold
when they realize a top developer is
going to want to live by a lake
in a 2 million dollar you know six
bedroom
on five acres as opposed to a two
million dollar
two bedroom in a city that's completely
dysfunctional
like the worst city in america today san
francisco
hey jason uh it's deirdre bosnick here
just want to switch gears a little bit
and talk about uber because we had a ceo
darmacos or shahi
uh on our air not too long ago and he
reiterated that the company is confident
that it can get to profitability in 2021
but the company never seems to say
how they're gonna get there i mean ride
sharing was
heading in that direction that has
adjusted ebitda profitability
but food delivery is deeply deeply
unprofitable they just bought another
unprofitable player so
just explain this to me how do they get
to that profitability
target when they're going they're
doubling down on an unprofitable
business
yeah that's a great question so um the
reason these businesses were
unprofitable is because we were in a dog
fight
and obviously i'm still a very large
uber shareholder i've got
a very significant portion of my net
worth in it which wasn't fun when it hit
15
a share but i believe in the company and
when you're in a dog fight like that
it's not that it's an unprofitable
business it's that you're trying to kill
your competitors and you're trying to be
one of the last two people standing
and what we're going to see uh and we we
saw it with the post-based acquisition
which is a sleeper acquisition what
people don't understand about postmates
is that company is loved by their user
base
and they have dna outside of just food
delivery they have they have an api
the ability for people who want to
deliver other stuff to build it into
their products
so that's probably why they bought it
but we'll see this great consolidation
occur it's going to be the biggest
m a bonanza we've ever seen in our
lifetimes the next two years
because tech valuations are up because
the cash positions are so high
and because other businesses especially
traditional ones
are on the floor and when you have that
kind of chip stack discrepancy at the
poker table
the small stacks are going to get
dominated and they're going to get taken
out by the big stacks the big stacks
being
the ubers and the amazons etc
so that business will easily be
profitable once there aren't
eight or nine people doing investing
which
i think the public looks at oh it's a
money losing business those will become
profitable
and if you look at the layoffs that
occurred
i think all the big companies putting us
uber aside
had a great moment of okay this is a
crisis let's not waste it
let's get our staff size down without
killing morale because we have the cover
of the pandemic to do that
and so the a lot of these companies just
hired like crazy
and now they're right size the truth is
these companies can operate
a company like google could operate and
have 90 of the revenue with half the
number of employees they don't do that
because they're building for the future
so you're going to see that natural
attrition and optimization
and we will be sitting here in a year or
two and this entire discussion of oh my
god ride sharing can be
profitable food delivery can be
profitable will look like a really silly
discussion
all right jason want to shift gears yet
again we got to be in sixth gear by now
for all the gears that we're shifting
talk about this count house
controversy that you are in the middle
of
to simplify it it's silicon valley
investors versus
the tech press and the argument from the
side of
you and some others has been it's
unbalanced it's unfair
the tech press has been overly negative
and and seeking controversy i've got a
perspective on this
that i want to run by you i think the
startup content ecosystem
has just changed uh 15 years ago
none of the investors cared what the new
york times was writing because there was
silicon valley insider there was giga
own there was tech crunch
there was paid content but now you're an
angel investor
all malek went to vc michael arrington
and mg
siegler are investors rafat ali started
he's an entrepreneur he started
youtube right so so we've moved into
this different
phase where that kind of silicon valley
celebrating the startup and the investor
blogger culture doesn't have oxygen
anymore you can't make money doing that
and now you need the new york times
to write about you guys and they're not
doing the same thing that those
publications used to do i mean isn't
that really the issue
it really is a multi-level issue and i
think you hit on some of the the themes
that are correct for people who don't
understand exactly
the inside baseball we're talking about
the tech community feels aggrieved that
the new york times
only writes about negative things and
there's one layer which is
you know we used to be this band of
loved
radical world positive you know
entrepreneurs making cool products
people loved
and then this guy named mark zuckerberg
came he was a marauder
and he did a lot of bad things and the
companies got so big that they really
started to have influence right and
when trump got elected and people blamed
it on
you know facebook and and putin buying
you know
anti-hillary ads racist ads with rubles
that's when i saw this thing crack
wide open another thing that's happened
during all of this and
tech industry's sensitive and i've been
a journalist for 20 years and an
investor for 10. so i've been on both
sides of this
nobody likes their press but everybody
wants more press so i get it
and no press is perfect and human beings
who build companies are not perfect
but the amount of power that tech now
has i mean we're here sitting here
talking
about how we're the trillion dollar
companies and we're eating up
all of you know these traditional
companies that don't even know how to
compete anymore i mean
they just look pathetic compared to the
tech companies ability to innovate
and delight customers there's another
thing that's occurred
and this is what i think is the core
issue and and this whole thing got
overheated on the weekend
to the point at which journalists got
harassed i got harassed people were
getting something called docs which
means your home address gets
published and i told everybody listen
everybody's got to take a cooler on this
take the discussion offline and that's
what i'm i'm saying here today on cnbc
is please
let's just take this offline and work
out our differences privately
but the core issue is we have a
generation of journalists who are coming
up who are not
john like you or carl who are
who believe in capitalism plus democracy
they are
socialists they believe in social
democracy and they believe that
capitalism is a force
that is bad for humanity and they are
going to get a very rude awakening if
they win
because if you think it sucks to you
know
deal with the government for your
education or for health care right now
wait until your social network or
your transportation is provided by the
government
you you do not want to live in a world
ev where the government
provides services for you and you're
dependent on them and you do not want to
watch the united states lose its
dominant position in the world
because there is somebody right behind
us who jails
journalists and who puts people in jail
because of their religious beliefs and
it's called
china and it's the chinese communist
party that america is up against and
these young millennials who believe in
socialism
they don't understand it's the road to
communism and i believe in
universal health care but man this has
gotten out of control
the press cnbc excluded is an
anti-capitalist
i i mean at the crux of this argument
what i heard was that there weren't
enough good stories being written but
you said it yourself as big
tech becomes bigger i know that you're
not a huge fan of mark zuckerberg so
doesn't it make sense to hold these
companies responsible
earlier on especially as they become
some of the biggest companies in the
world but
i also want to ask you specifically
because a bunch of ceos and founders
they did take note of the dispute a few
of them speaking out
in support of media scrutiny you had the
redfin ceo glenn kellman you also had
the base camp founder dha do you worry
that
uh your role in this in the back and
forth could hurt your ability to make
investments to
you know get close to founders and
companies that you want to invest in
100 no the people who i invest in are
capitalists the people who are taking
the other position
are social democrats or socialists so
i'm not worried about that at all in
fact
you know me strongly coming out on cnbc
and saying i believe
in capitalism plus democracy not
socialism or communism
makes me the most attractive place to
come for uh getting a check as an early
stage investor it actually has
built my brand is that i'm
pro-capitalism and i can't believe i'm
sitting here on cnbc
defending capitalism i mean that's the
point america has gotten to is that we
actually believe
socialism and communism is a better
operating system
it is not we've just gotten soft as
americans where we for some bizarre
reason
think that capitalism is bad now
there should be absolute scrutiny on all
of these companies but when i talk to
journalists today
they are calling me this terrible thing
happened at uber this terrible thing
happened at another company
comment on this terrible thing comment
on this terrible thing when i come on
cnbc
you always balance it hey tell me about
something new and exciting oh hey
there's some problems with this company
it's the percentage of coverage and if
you look at the new york times
and it doesn't take a genius to do the
math just look at 20 tech stories
18 or 19 of them are going to be just
the bad story attack and i say to them
hey would you please cover calm.com and
what they're doing for mental health
please cover blockable and the
affordable housing we're working on
they're like
i can't get that through my editor i
have to write about mark zuckerberg
i have to write about palantir i have to
write about how terrible this person is
and you know what we're tired of it on
our side and
we're just going to route around the
press that's what's happening in silicon
valley
we're now getting follower accounts on
twitter that
are greater than the journalists and
that's the other
underlying thing here the tech industry
killed the news business
we you know you look at craigslist they
decimated absolutely decimated
classifieds
then you look at what goog the duopoly
of google and facebook did to add
revenue in newspapers
and newspapers peaked right as the
internet emerged
and it went straight downhill so we have
to have a very nuanced discussion about
the
importance of a free press which i spent
two decades of my life in
uh you know and covering as a journalist
and
maybe just calm this beef down a little
bit and all i'm asking for is a little
balance if you want to beat us up
and you want to criticize us for four
out of five stories go for it
it only makes us better at what we do i
am absolutely open to criticism every
time i come on this program i get a
massive amount of criticism i get to
tweak my game a little bit
i take it to heart and i try to make
myself and i try to make my game what i
do every day of investing companies just
you know two three percent better every
time but i would love it
if the new york times would just cover
one or two world positive companies i
invest in
out of 250 companies two or three of my
companies have stumbled and deserved
criticism what about the other 247 can i
get a profile of a company doing
something good that's all i'm asking for
please some balance but
balance balance in the media is uh is
something
we'll always deal with and in terms of
capitalism jason i mean i don't need to
tell you
the inequality that's been created that
jay powell comments on
uh in his testimonies uh and the way in
which central banks have co-opted a lot
of activity
is there is why you're hearing
complaints and we'll talk about we need
to have that nuance obviously
and i'm all for raising the minimum wage
i'm for universal health care
let's have those discussions without
just vilifying the tech
as the enemy
jason thanks it's always great we love
having you kick off the hour
jason keller thanks for having me on i
appreciate it everybody stay safe
well talk about surge pricing shares of
uber and lyft
are surging this morning as california
passes prop
22 meaning drivers will be able to
remain
independent contractors and not
employees early uber investor and
founder of inside.com jason kalakanis
joins us now jason i'll bet you're as
subdued as
ever about this but really
this was not nearly as close as the
polls suggested i mean
58 is pretty resounding
we got uh the concession on this pretty
early in the night
do we now move on to figuring out how
these companies can make
conditions and safety nets better for
workers
absolutely and you know just i would
like to thank the media for doing such a
great job covering
what is obviously a little bit of chaos
today
and for the american people to be
patient and get every
vote counter because everyone does count
prop 22
um is really uh a parallel to what we're
seeing across the country and
trump's absolutely shocking and
outstanding performance we heard roger
just talk about it before i came on air
how is this possible that trump got all
these votes well i believe that there
is a war going on within our country
between
uh rural voters who would like to live
their lives and not be told how to live
those lives
and an emerging hysterical socialist
left and which we sometimes refer to as
coastal elites
but those coastal elites actually do not
agree with the hysterical left
and they don't want to tell people how
to work and what
what prop 22 did was and the reason why
70 of drivers didn't want it
is they wanted to force people who very
much enjoyed
picking their own hours and making
arguably
fifteen to thirty dollars an hour in the
face
of having other choices like working for
mcdonald's for ten dollars an hour
mcdonald's forcing and fighting tooth
and nail for decades against a minimum
wage increase
or the fact that amazon and apple
had to raise their minimum wages to
fifteen dollars an hour
to compete against gig work that
door dash postmates lyft uber and many
other companies
had put out there that was so much more
compelling
to the average american as an
entry-level job
or as a side hustle a way to make that
extra hundred dollars
that they voted unanimously that they do
not
want the government telling them how to
work and they don't want to show up
in a in a uniform and work at mcdonald's
from 5 a.m
to 4 p.m so not put their kids through
school or drop them
how do the companies make it better from
here though because
yes yes this is this is a repudiation
of the state saying we know what's best
for everybody here this is direct
democracy people saying
no here's what we want but there's still
this
issue of safety net we saw it happen
during kovid when so many drivers were
not able
to have those fares and those right
we're still in this period i i shouldn't
say during covet as if it's passed
uh there are a lot of possibilities that
your dara khazrasahi's
uh and others tony shu have put forth
for ways that workers could be protected
how quickly
does that move forward at this point
one of the great things about this split
election where it appears biden's going
to win
by just a hair and we might have the
senate go slightly to the gop
is that these people we sent to
washington are going to need to get
together
and look at something like the minimum
wage which has not changed since 2009
seven dollars and 25 cents australia has
a
i think a 14 15 minimum wage at this
point the second highest in the world
and companies tech companies
specifically are
leading the charge amazon which is
derided and they want to break it up
has a 15 million a 15 an hour in wage
uber run really exceptionally well
is putting money into people's safety
net what we're building in the
technology industry
is a second safety net there's already a
safety net
unemployment welfare food stamps all the
different programs we have in this
country paid for by taxpayers
what the gig economy did and boy are
these
idiot politicians in california who are
destroying the state
and driving the top leaders out of the
greatest state in the nation it's not
the greatest city but it is the greatest
state with the greatest coastline the
greatest weather the greatest technology
these idiots are driving people to texas
nevada and florida so that they can have
more freedom to run their companies and
not have these
idiots these absolutely incompetent
tell them how to run companies and we
are doing a better job at leadership
than they are
and it's infuriating and that's why
they're lost and that's why trump is so
close to winning
sorry i'm um you you mentioned okay
bringing you back to the topic at hand
you did mention minimum wage i do think
it's worth pointing out that in florida
there was a vote
to increase the minimum wage but i want
to ask you specifically about
uber of course uh you're an early
investor there
i think it was interesting that uber
made adjustments to the app ahead of the
vote to make it that more of a
marketplace
and then there was just a report out
from morgan stanley
saying that prop 22 could give uber an
advantage in the competition
for driver supply because it is the
larger app the larger player
and the argument now that you could see
where drivers concentrate their hours on
uber
how do you see prop 22 impacting the
competition between uber and lyft
and impacting these companies in perhaps
ways we may not have anticipated
because there was just so much of a
focus on whether or not 22 would pass or
not
yeah i mean this has been it's a great
question this has been a super overhang
for
literally i don't know every year after
the second or third year of uber when
they started to be so successful and
they started to spread like wildfire
the when you add these regulations
whether it's regulating social media
it basically pulls up the ladder for
competitors below because
the companies with the most money the
biggest war chests get to defend
themselves so all the regulation would
have done
you know part of me was like wow this
would be pretty great if prop 22
fails because then uber gets to say
you're all full-time you work the hours
we want you to work we're lowering the
rate you're going to get
and you got to wear an uber logo and
t-shirt and you got to drive a certain
type of car
it would actually standardize the
process and make it less of a
marketplace when travis started the
company i
asked him hey travis why don't we give
everybody an uber shirt
or why don't we provide them with car
washes because
i would get friends we'd be like i just
went into an uber it was dirty
and he said jason it's a marketplace we
cannot exert how they deliver the
service once we do that they're
employees
well guess what if you make them
employees we can
we at uber unless i'm saying we i'm a
small shareholder now but uber could
then say you know what
you can't work for lyft you can't work
for door dash
you can only work for lyft so then to
the person on top that's
not the biggest that's what would have
happened so uber wins either way in this
but what's most important is a vibrant
competition
if you want to fight the real enemy
walmart's paying people eleven dollars
an hour
mcdonald's is paying them seven eight
nine ten dollars an hour
let's start there and let's start a
program
within the greatest country in the world
where we raise the minimum wage
five to ten percent a year yep
florida started that process jason but
you know there are still those who
believe
this is not about telling the companies
how to run their employee base
it's about those laid off drivers who
filed for unemployment
that you and i paid their benefits
because the company
never paid into the pool and that it's
just labor arbitrage
okay guess what if you're a real estate
broker
if you're a freelance writer you have
freelance journalists i'm sure who work
at cnbc
poor vox an up-and-coming uh you know
media company had to lay off or fire
every journalist in california because
of these idiot
absolutely incompetent uh you know
backers of these type of ab5 programs
who said you can't have freelance
journalists anymore
and you know what we need to do we need
to let americans decide
how they distribute their labor
pre-pandemic we had the lowest
unemployment of our lifetime look at the
free market
look at how it's operating if we have
the lowest unemployment and wages are
going
up for people in that bracket and
walmart
it has to raise to 11 to compete with
amazon who's at 15
they're reacting and even apple who had
a disgracefully low
uh store price uh hourly a wage for
their store employees and they got
absolutely admonished for it and
rightfully so since they're so
unbelievably profitable everybody has to
compete for that class of employees
there is no loser in a vibrant
competitive
entry-level market like this right
people are choosing
that they want to drive four hours and
be able to pick their kids up and take
them to soccer
well because working an eight-hour shift
sucks
and having to wear that uniform
capitalism is supposed to work and i
think we can all
acknowledge it needs some guard rails
but uh not necessarily
and that's the minimum wage so let's all
work on that instead of picking one
company
because you don't happen to like them a
lot of people disagree about the minimum
wage but that's for another day jason
calacanis thank you
okay a little bit give them a little bit
on the minimum wage all right
seven dollars is ridiculous let's go to
ten and just call it a day
let's start somewhere all right
disgraceful
good to see you jason
[Music]
we are back at one market in san
francisco in just about 24 hours
not too far from here apple is expected
to unveil three new
iphones the event coming as the stock
has sputtered
we're joined now by angel investor jason
calacanis along with the investor dan
niles
de costello of course is still with us
and the big news dan i see you jason
good to see you as well thanks for being
here
um is the move you made in the stock
just a couple of days ago yeah i mean i
wouldn't call it that big a move but
we were we were along the same short
apple well yeah but
this is the way i look at it the stock's
up over 35 for the year
but look at the financials the revenues
are up one percent
the earnings are down five percent and
these new phones the big innovation is
we might
get a purple and green color wow that's
that's exciting
and um there's no 5g on the phone
um you know there's not you're gonna get
a better camera but the cameras we
currently have are pretty good and maybe
you can
charge some other products so for us
it's a small position you have to
remember we're actually
very long the supply chain for apple
where you've had apple burn
a lot of inventory over the past six
months so are
one of our largest positions the company
called lumentum they provide the
the lasers for apple and that stock's
trading at about 12 and a half times
earnings and we think that's a huge
runway for them
regardless of apple so what turns you
more bullish on the story then
i mean quite honestly you know if you
look at the big trends in tech right now
what do you have well you've got four
and a half billion people on the planet
out of the seven and a half billion
people who already have cell phones
the improvements you're getting are very
incremental and last year you had
smartphone unit sales declined for the
first time
since the iphone was launched so you're
talking about
a very slow growth market for a product
that's over 50 percent of their revenues
and they're at the high end of the
market
so until they get a 5g phone out and
that's gonna probably come next year
it's hard for me to see somebody running
out and spending a thousand dollars
so they can buy a purple phone and with
a better camera so
for me apple has had a great run great
buy back
obviously great dividend but you know
the big moves we made last week quite
honestly is we shorted the
bonds and we bought silicon valley bank
which is down 39 percent year-to-date
we bought lincoln financial with a six p
e that's down
23 or so year to date and we think the
financials actually and that trades at a
six p e
we think those are some of the more
interesting spaces of the market where
these stocks have gotten absolutely
killed and if we're not going into a
recession
you're going to have a big bounce in in
the financials and so that's what
those were the big moves we actually
made last week what jason does apple
need to do in your estimation to get an
investor like dan niles more excited
about the story yeah you gotta fire tim
cook it's a disaster i mean i think they
haven't done anything innovative since
this device which is magical the ipods
i thought you were joking you're being
no i'm being dead serious i think it's
time for him to uh pass the baton
because
the steve jobs passed away the phone has
been in decline since
no there's no reason to upgrade your
phone so peak phone was what 2015
and it prints money sure but the major
problem is
they believe that any company uh that
innovates out there is not as good as
theirs
they need to watch what zuckerberg did
with instagram and whatsapp
and what google did with android and
with instagram
dan's gonna buy back into the stock if
they buy tesla if they buy peloton if
they buy spotify
and they start putting that 200 billion
to work yes or no
yes or no well i mean if they had that i
mean if they put peloton in every store
would you buy
uh i'm not a well i i like my friend the
broader point that jason's
but the point the point the point he's
making actually has a lot of validity to
it in the sense that if you think
the one thing i will say tim cook has
done better than any ceo is deal with
the current administration
and so he's put his personal feelings
aside
obviously openly gay man highest profile
ceo
on wall street and he's done a great job
dealing with the trump administration so
more than any other ceo you have to give
him a lot of credit for that now on the
innovation pro
front i completely agree with them it's
something i've said before apple
since the passing of steve jobs but to
be fair he's a once in a generation
maybe somebody like an elon musk that
you're going to see what's the stock
really
stock up 250 or i forgot what the number
is that number may be wrong
my point because the stock is up a lot
because they're extracting
so much money from their loyal fans and
margin on this well don't forget they
have a huge buy back
they have a massive dividend and so
that's great that the stock does really
well right now but
if you're looking out for this company
over the next two three five years
once that buyback starts to peter out
and that balance sheet
starts to wind down they're not
innovating that much they're one year
behind samsung on 5g
when you're trying to have somebody
cough up a thousand bucks for a new
phone
i think that's a big deal so you know i
think the stock's going to actually do
relatively well between now and when
they have to report the fourth quarter
if you think of last year right
stock did great for the first nine
months then they had to sell 50 more
phones in the fourth quarter and i was
on your show in august
saying i think apple's gonna have a huge
problem because people are
worried about china yet they're somehow
not worried about apple that's got high
teen stuff
like 20 bucks off the high yeah but that
has nothing to do with what jason's
talking about in terms of innovation
here will not get you there yeah and
that's their core problem
they are resting on the laurels of steve
jobs legacy they need to put tim [ __ ]
tim cook in another position get elon
musk in there let him run the company
find somebody like that
somebody who is maniacal about product i
mean
let's just sit here and realize that
ipods are the greatest
headphones ever made and that's the
greatest thing they've done over there
in 10 years
it's a disaster and if they take that
store footprint and they put a model
three in every one
if they put a peloton tread in there and
i've been using the tread it is
exceptional peloton is the tesla or the
iphone
of sports equipment it would go
gangbusters they would go from 500 000
peloton subscribers to at least 10
million
that's the type of acquisition you need
to make if you're going to compete
and they just have way too much pride
they think that they make the best
products in the world and nobody else
can
incorrect tesla peloton facebook
google all making wonderful products
right now the pixel 3
with google fi is a better experience
than the iphone i have both i use both
i've used every version of both phones
the google pixel is a better
phone i mean you agree with this or you
disagree
i just think there's a huge opportunity
around apple tv
and combining what they've built there
was with the streaming service
that would give them an enormous
competitive advantage over the
other players in the streaming space and
i just
is it is it is it coming is it coming
next week is again the next couple weeks
this is what i would say with regards to
that i think apple tv
is going to be a humongous
disappointment and this is why
why do you get a tv service it's for
content
now there's something you were asking me
that is a question
why do you use the television yeah
but there's this little company called
disney that's coming out and they plan
on bundling
disney along with espn along with hulu
for 12.99 game over they're going to
absolutely crush
everybody else who's trying to launch a
streaming service including the
incumbent netflix if you're them
you've got a rather big problem well
their stock has shown that and well the
funny thing is netflix's subscribers
in the us decline sequentially for the
first time in a decade that's without
having disney in there pushing their
content so you look at apple and you go
well
where's the big store of content that
they're going to have now the good news
is they have an install base of 900
million iphones
at 1.4 billion devices there's going to
be some set of people
that do say okay i'm going to buy that i
haven't heard anybody on this desk talk
about the services business yeah but
that the reason is
services this is business in and of
itself the services business is 10
of revenues iphones is 50 of revenues
there's a reason why
revenues are up 1 year over year and
earnings are down 5.
it's great to say well don't look at
this go look at that 10
piece well yeah but that 10 piece isn't
big enough to move the needle now
wearables
is i think 19 or so of revenues that's
growing
very rapidly but again you have to look
at this
in total yeah the stock's done well but
it's not what it's doing to this point
you're looking at this and going all
right there's a big gaping hole between
now
and this time next year when they have a
5g phone i'm looking at a company like
that division
which is changing gears they're
you're going to see a microsoft amazon
google
all launched game streaming services and
if you look at a tweet i put out last
week
i've got two nerds living in my basement
my wife prefers to call them children
but you know they were all geeked up
about the new launch of world of
warcraft coming
right and we're we're in hawaii surfing
and they're like busy
making names for the world of warcraft
launch right that's gone from 12 million
subs
to less than three and this whole free
to play genre everybody's heard of
fortnite pub g
that started in the beginning of 2017.
that's crushed that whole sector
i mean activision's 34 percent from its
52 week
now what happens with streaming though
is you go from being able to play games
on your console
they're only about 50 million xboxes
playstations etc sold last year to all
of a sudden if you can play that on the
one and a half
billion smartphones sold every year
that becomes much more interesting and
call of duty which is the big activision
game
that's expected to be able to be played
on mobile coming up soon so
those are things that are interesting
there's a lot of content from those
games i just think apple tv will not
exist in five to ten years
not the hardware part but the
subscription they'll cancel that service
they have no business being in that
they're
horrible at content and their whole
concept of like
not doing edgy content in the age of
secession and hbo
battling it out with netflix netflix to
see who can be more edgy and amc
it's just a disaster uh they need to
really rethink everything but the
subscription revenue we're seeing many
startups in silicon valley
com.com is one of the ones i invested in
we own five percent of that company
they're going to do 160 million in
subscriptions this year
and they fork over 15 to 30 percent of
that to apple that is a very real
business it may be a slow burn
but it is the future of consumption
people don't have to make a cognitive
decision to buy a product
they can just subscribe and cancel at
any time that leads to a lot of sampling
and it's going to be a
ginormous place honestly if if apple
bought a content
maker like i mean if you think about the
streaming services coming you've got
disney
obviously the juggernaut in the space
but comcast is coming as well they you
they own nbc universal right
obviously a lot of content there and
then you have a t launching their own
streaming service
they own warner which obviously harry
potter et cetera
and so you look at all of this and you
say well what's the big content that
apple owns
no way and you go well if they bought
some of these media companies that are
now trading at like six times
you know earnings which given apple's
trading about 17 times you go okay at
least you could make the argument we've
got some interesting content
that people might want to watch right
now they're doing one-off deals with
some
you know people like oprah and steven
spielberg
about them having no audacious
nature in them to buy things iger was
like you know what
pixar marvel uh i'll take it all
star wars i'll take everything they
don't have to they don't sit there going
oh you know what star wars we didn't
make star wars oh we didn't create the
marvel universe therefore we can't buy
it that's why we own disney
we love that they're going to be the
winner 200 billion
what are they doing with it they bought
beats for 2 billion
i mean zuckerberg paid 19 billion for
whatsapp app that was i think 20 of the
company at the time or 15
of the company can you imagine apple
making a bet like that
of course not that's why you have to
take the guy in the seat who's been a
great steward for 10 years
and move them out and put somebody in
there who has the guts to buy something
provocative thoughts as always i would
expect nothing less from jason calacanis
he's going to stick with us dan thank
you for being here
great to get your insights on all things
tech decosta's going to stick around
as well coming up big tech under fire us
states taking aim at google
an anti-trust announcement expected in a
matter of hours
how the valley is preparing for
regulation halftime report back right
after this
about 90 minutes from now about 30
attorneys general are expected to
announce an anti-trust investigation
into google
our elan moy joins us from the steps of
the supreme court where that
announcement will be made elon
that's right scott we're expecting this
announcement to come at 2 p.m
right here in front of the supreme court
and have now been able to confirm
that nearly every single state in the
country will be participating
in this anti-trust investigation against
google
the one notable exception is california
scott where you are
and of course home to google's
headquarters now that's according to a
source familiar with the case
the california state ag's office has
sent me a statement that says the state
remains deeply concerned
and committed to fighting
anti-competitive behavior
now the state that is leading this case
is texas the attorney general there is
ken paxton he's a republican
and he's indicated that this case will
center on three big questions
one is google stifling competition two
is it restricting access
and three is it harming consumers i'm
also told that the investigation
will include a demand that google turn
over documents
related to its advertising business now
for its part google has
already released a statement
preemptively saying that its services
help people create more choice and
support
thousands of jobs so clearly scott this
is not google's first rodeo
fortunately or unfortunately for the
company they've grown well accustomed to
these types of investigations
both here at home and abroad back over
to you yeah elon thanks so much that's
elon muir outside the supreme court
for us okay the gang's all back jeff
richards is back from ggv
uh your industry is under fire i don't
know how else to to say it
what are you all thinking about it jeff
you first
yeah i mean i think the the point that
elon made about is it better for
consumers
there's no question our lives are better
because of amazon because of google
uh perhaps because of facebook the
question that i think comes back to is
are we stifling competition
and that's where it gets challenging you
have 90 search share you have a dominant
position in maps
you own a lot of the advertising
infrastructure in the united states so
it's a fair question but i personally
feel like my life's better because of
google so it's hard to then
wind back the clock and ask about those
other factors i think i feel like the
regulators always
you know fight the last war i'm not
saying anything i don't think i'm saying
anything original here but
they went after microsoft when microsoft
at least for those of us out here felt
like much less of a threat they're going
after google now when there are
plenty of other um areas of tech that
feel like they're monopolies some
certainly facebook
owns the social graph and and and
decides who can and can't have access to
that via their apis et cetera
um you know the app store is as jason
mentioned earlier in the show
you know you got to pay the vig you know
you get to pay the 30 on
on any subscription that goes through
there if there was a competitive app
store
the app store wouldn't be able to charge
30 on subscriptions so
i i just kind of feel like the
regulators once again are going after
yesterday's
uh issues and there and there are bigger
issues facing uh the competitive
landscape you're not being dismissive
though about
some of the you know self-inflicted
issues that need to be
dealt with one way or the other 100 a
lot so many of these things are own
goals there was an advertising
issue uh uh raised the other week by the
new
the folks running a new brave browser
about um hidden pages that uh google ads
was
surfacing to make sure making sure data
was passed between uh
advertising partners those those things
are own goals and self-inflicted wounds
that the
folks out here just have to get smarter
about the one thing i'll add and then i
know i know you're going to jump in with
something aggressive but
the the my reputation exactly but think
about
where google amazon facebook are
dominant particularly google and amazon
is in the us
300 million people in the us there's 7.3
billion people in the world
what happens as the next billion come
online in latin america southeast asia
india
africa you know do we want google going
after those consumers or do we want to
hand the keys to those markets to other
tech companies around the world i think
that's got to be part of the equation as
well it's not just about the us as we
have a global market now
yeah i just think historically you would
buy on an anti-trust investigation
because it means the company is truly
meaningful
and there's no way anybody in our
government can take these
success stories and ankle them in the
face of china picking the winners
right i mean we have tick tock the first
chinese company
that has hit any type of scale in
america on our shores why we allow them
in our country when twitter
is not allowed in china is beyond
comprehension for me
and you can be sure the chinese
government has access to those
microphones and cameras of tens of
millions of americans using tick tock
putting that aside uh i think there's
one of two outcomes here one
they put google in the penalty box and
maybe it impacts revenue in the low
single digits
and the way that would happen is because
google has been so
aggressive in pushing down the organic
search results and putting their own
services above it
and they put five or six links up there
that you can't tell or add so if the
antitrust people would like a place to
look
put a hundred consumers in front of a
google search and say tell me what's ads
and what's not
and sixty or seventy percent of them
will not know the difference and that's
where they could really hurt google
five to ten percent the master play for
google is to say you know what you got
us
we're gonna spin out youtube we're gonna
spin out nest
and that will create more shareholder
value because those assets unleashed
outside of alphabet
would do even better which is why they
set up alphabet to begin with
alphabet being set up as a way to
distance larry who does not want to
speak in public when's the last time you
had larry on the show
oh never he doesn't talk publicly he is
not available
something's wrong with his throat he
does have a thing but he is not
available to talk about it they've been
very smart
about architecting this company so
nobody's in charge and nobody knows
where the bodies are buried let me ask
you about
facebook um koslow
says monopoly on the the social network
you know jeff
and enlisting you know like my life is
better off with google
he used the word perhaps when talking
about facebook
how do you see facebook well facebook is
really the cause of all this they were
the first company here in silicon valley
to really abuse the customer base
at an audacious level and then they did
something that was really
distasteful here they treated other
entrepreneurs
like the chinese companies and
entrepreneurs treat america in other
words they had no respect for our
intellectual property
and that has made them so loathsome and
hated uh here in the community
by taking everything that evan spiegel
did with snapchat and just stealing it
like a photocopy
and they put the target on their back
and then for zuckerberg to come out and
say like oh it's ridiculous that an
election could be swung by our
services while the sales team is
embedded in trump and hillary and
everybody else's campaign
with sales documents saying help we'll
help you win your election and then
zuckerberg says it's not possible
it's that kind of arrogance that
zuckerberg has that has led to the
government
having to do something now what can they
do can they get them to uh
break up and sell instagram or whatsapp
i don't think so but they're not gonna
let them buy the next ones
uh and that's really i think the
existential risk for zuckerberg
is he has been such a bad steward of
that company he has been
such a bad human being and how he's
treated his own users
that he needs to be stopped and if we
didn't have zuckerberg in this ecosystem
people would look at tech a completely
different way i believe
and they could solve the entire problem
with one simple product innovation
if you logged into facebook today and
said would you like to subscribe to
facebook for eight dollars a month sixty
dollars a year
then they would have the air cover they
could just say you know what dick and
jason scott you all
decided that you don't want to give us
your data you you're a subscriber
we collect none of your data you think
then that would solve the whole problem
you think facebook is
truly on top of the issue of data
privacy at this point they're a disaster
i mean the whole concept
was to move fast and break things
congratulations you broke the democracy
you broke people's privacy that was
their explicit goal
and and that's why i think if you look
at a lot of the problems we have here in
silicon valley with the black eye with
you know people looking and not trusting
us anymore it really goes back to
zuckerberg's approach which was
put a product out there let the chips
fall where they may
and that really is um very hard to
compete against
if twitter decides you know let's be
judicious here let's check the ads
before they go up on twitter
and zuckerberg's like check the ads no
that's friction just put the heads up i
don't care if it's in rubles i don't
care if it says hillary's a racist
just put that stuff up that's what they
did well look i it's hard to say
anything after jason that doesn't sound
equivocal you know or
meek uh but uh you know ben thompson a
sort of a thought leader if you will out
out here
wrote a little while back that the way
to think about
going after regulating these companies
should be different in each case not
not uh not uh like the same way across
the broad broad brush and
his thought on facebook is you know they
probably shouldn't be able to
uh be allowed to buy other social
networks uh like instagram for example i
think that's probably
at least an interesting idea his his way
of thinking about
you have to treat these these companies
differently when you think about
regulating them i would just add that
to chase's point if you look at the
reaction to libra which is facebook's
kind of
uh toe in the water in the
cryptocurrency blockchain area
it's been fairly negative in washington
dc and sort of a fairly
yeah well okay very uh what could go
wrong i mean right
right congress and i think that's your
indication that that the government
realizes they probably
waited too long on some of these other
fronts and so the the reaction libra has
been pretty negative
hey twitter's not out out uh you know at
the shining beacon on the hill in some
respects as well
i mean people describe it as a cesspool
at certain points for
the discourse that it puts forth
as well there are you know issues that
that exists with that service too how
would you handle that today if you were
still running it
i think that these ceos and leaders
these companies
and you know and i know jack and the
team there think about this stuff all
the time
have to do something that's probably
to date been um would make them cringe
and that's
you have to start treating all the these
accounts differently meaning that
you've got high authority accounts like
i don't know newspaper accounts new york
times new york post
you know pick your pick your publication
that um that may may be allowed to
tweet things that a user who just signed
up yesterday and has zero followers
shouldn't so for example i'll give you a
quick example back when i was ceo
isis notably assassinated some hostages
they had captured
they tweeted photos of the assassination
and we
we said okay any account that tweets
these photos out it was mostly isis
accounts
at the time we'll suspend them you know
you can't tweet photos of
people being executed um the next day or
not the next day a couple hours later i
think it was the new york post
um tweets out what is the cover of the
that evening's new york post
um and it's the photos of these guys
being executed so now you're like okay
well now what do we do do we have i just
think that these companies can't treat
all accounts uh
equally and consistently and have to
start um
thinking of different tiers of accounts
and accounts that have just signed up
and have no followers and
and you know no avatar and haven't uh
sent their phone number in
maybe shouldn't be allowed to reply in
real time to leaders of the world and
and and high authority accounts on the
platform etc or at least
have those things only be seen by their
followers and not everybody um
that's you know if you tell the ceo's
companies this thing like oh great i got
a hard
i have a hard enough time now i got to
start thinking about treating these
accounts differently
but i think that's probably the way
forward as hard as that is less than
quicker yeah no i would just say
i think if you look at twitter it
started as a free speech experiment and
we were all very
pro that uh but when you hit scale
things change obviously and i think
there's a really illustrative example
uh with the assassinations or the
murders
why not just make everybody verified and
just say you have to have a real name
like facebook does
and if you if you don't choose your real
name if you don't verify then you're
going to be part of this
uh underbelly that people have to opt in
to see now the reason they wouldn't do
that there's a public company and then
they're going to go flat for three
quarters and then you all are going to
give them a hard time and their stock's
going to collapse and that is really the
problem and this
reason why companies are staying private
longer and why we have this issue that
we've been talking about
uh for months about are these companies
waiting too long to go
public they're waiting because they
can't take dramatic action like this
without the
the stock getting cratered and then all
the employees are underwater i think in
the
in it it's as most things are people
don't like to hear this
um but it's more complicated than just
you know verifying all the accounts
you've got
um um uh uh people who are um
under political pressure in lots of
countries outside the united states
where you're not allowed to speak freely
uh like tunisia where the sort of the
the arab springs
really started and swept across north
africa those people were all tweeting
under assumed names and that's how they
were able to organize and protest
without the government knowing like ah
that's you know this guy who lives at
this address let's go tie him up before
the protest
um so it's more complicated than that
there are also people who
can't verify their accounts because they
don't you have banned their permanent
phone numbers et cetera
no i don't think you can ban the
president united states even if he's
using people
it's not twitter's problem that he was
elected president
um he's the president of the united
states as a platform to be able to
say what he he wants to say whether
irrespective no matter what it is
uh i just think you can't it's not any
elected official for that matter
yeah i just don't think you can ban the
president of the united states from the
platform wait so if an elected official
is wrong
you know you know sheriff of washington
county and
in in michigan that's a different thing
than the president of the united states
of america got it
all right again i just don't think you
can it goes back to my point
i don't think you can have a have a
terms of service that says we treat
every account equally it causes these
companies to have to
jump through hoops and twist themselves
into a pretzel and you see that with the
way
people think about well this trump's
tweet
xyz didn't really break this rule for
this reason i just think you should say
look we're not gonna
do anything to the president united
states account he's the president united
states all right
we'll get final thoughts from you after
a quick break gentlemen thanks so much
for being here jeff richards ggv
jason calacanis good to be here thank
you candace incorporated
all right we'll be right back and it is
time now for an old-fashioned squawk
alley feed
although today the segment could really
just be called reading jason's twitter
feed
he's nothing if not outspoken and
controversial
angel investor in inside.com jason
calicanis is back with us and jason
let's start with one of these tweets
peloton last night
a prediction that they will launch or
buy three new products in the next three
to five years
grow tenfold from there and become the
amazon or apple of
gyms jason doesn't apple want to become
the apple of jim's as some have
speculated well thanks for having me and
i just wanted to
um say on 9 11's anniversary
thank you to um all of the families
who made that sacrifice that day and uh
specifically my little brother josh who
retired this year as a firefighter and
his
second or third call as a firefighter
from williamsburg was 911
and so a lot of time has passed but
still in all of those firefighters who
made that sacrifice
on 9 11. putting that aside and making a
hard shift to peloton
i am a huge fan of this company and i
think it has
netflix-like potential maybe not in the
number of users
but i do see a world in which they're
going to launch i think conservatively
you know six seven products there are
two products that are super obvious to
everybody one is called robot
i didn't hit that as a private investor
but that's a rowing machine that is
essentially peloton for rowing it's an
easy acquisition for them to make
but they probably just will build their
own it'll be easier for them to build
given what peloton knows
and then there's a um a unit called a
tonal t-o-n-a-l
also i'm not an investor in that company
but i had them on my podcast and i'm
addicted to that product
and what these products represent is
essentially the end of a company like
equinox
or any of these gyms because they've
made a product that is just such a
fabulous
value proposition and
not only is it a better product than a
better experience it's a better value
and so you know these devices will all
be in the
thousand dollar fifteen hundred dollar
range as we saw with the the tread two
uh i have the original tread which was
way overpriced at four thousand
something
uh but at two thousand and fifteen
hundred eventually it'll be it'll be a
gang busters but they'll come out with
an eclipse elliptical
a weight system like a pulley system
like the tonal a robot
and they'll probably have like a mirror
type you know portrait
panel and we'll see the million
subscribers go to 10 million
i'm not personally i haven't personally
bought peloton as a stock but i'm going
to start buying it over the next year or
so i'll be selective because the
market's pretty hot right now and i do
think there'll be a correction at some
point
and it it is really
got tailwinds because of people leaving
the city
and having larger homes as well so you
know i live in the suburbs now when i
lived in manhattan there was no way i
could have
you know more than one of these machines
but when you start to move out to them
you don't buy whatever
you're doing you can have three you
don't buy one of anything do you you got
multiple
teslas you're now looking at multiple
you have all the songs
so when you say that you expect a
peloton to come
either come out with uh multiple new
products
or acquire them when you look at tesla's
valuation
and when you look at the currency that
they now have
to go out and do these kinds of things
what do you think would be smart
i was you know kind of pushing on the
software and beyond just services media
driven services right now because
really what people want is the ability
to control and customize their exercise
experience
yeah i think there's an opportunity for
somebody to roll up a lot of players in
the space that's a great observation
john
you know robot and tonal those two
systems were easy to buy but peloton's
very good at building product they have
like that apple vibe
where they just know how to build
beautiful products so it would be very
smart for them as a blocking strategy i
think to buy tonal now and to buy a
robot now so that nobody can sort of
work backwards into the pellet into the
peloton space so i would do it as a
blocking strategy
and then we've invested in a lot of
private companies com.com the meditation
app
uh steezy is a dance app and fitbot is a
crossfitness app
that doesn't use a dedicated hardware
use whatever hardware you got
including like push-ups and setups in
your own body weight and all of those
businesses are doing you know
tens to hundreds of millions of dollars
a year in revenue so
i think with the spak movement you're
going to see a lot of those go public
and really who loses is what you always
have to ask where is this money coming
from i think that this is the new cable
tv
the new dvr the you know the new pc
every home will have one and when you
start looking at how
brilliantly peloton has priced this you
know when i go down to my peloton now
i see not only my wife and i logged into
it but i see my parents and my brother
you know when they come to spend time
with me in california
and they have accounts now so i'm
infecting them we call this real world
virality out here in silicon valley
uh over the shoulder virality you take
an uber with somebody and then you
download the app
so that is starting to happen for
peloton so i think the customer
acquisition cost is going to go down
and the prices for the hardware are
going to go down and then they'll stay
at that forty dollars a month which is
absurd value for a family to have a
forty dollar subscription
jason my reality though is
it's not exactly uh the real world i
think peloton still has some ways to go
in terms of pricing certainly
to be in every home uh like like cable
or
satellite tv um jason but let's move on
because i also want to get
your thoughts on nickel i'm sure they
are just as interesting
you your too soon sunicorn rule for some
of her
unicorns unicorn yeah yes
and so that's a reference to their nose
um you say that if a startup becomes
worth one billion dollars before they
launch their product
they're either going to fail or become a
fraud and of course
this follows trevor milton's response to
activist short seller hindenburg
which accused the company nicola of
being the latter
um okay break it down for us what is
nikola here then uh so i had a 12
trillion dollar evaluation i should add
much more than one yeah
all right so i had trevor on my podcast
um and he was very honest and he spent
you know like i think an hour and a half
on the pod talking very specifically
about their plans
and you know there's a possibility that
he'll hit some of these targets
um i don't believe that companies should
go public
before they have product market fit
we've seen this a couple of times
recently quibby
um you know they they were over a
billion dollars when they
uh were before they had their product
launch obviously their nose comes to
mind and magically the ar company in
florida
um you know has had ceo turnover and
their product is you know
still we're still waiting so it's just
it is a red flag for us in the valley it
doesn't mean it might not work out it
might work out
um but i think what you know retail
investors need to know when they buy
into
something like nikola is that they're
paying a price that's a hundred times
what private company investors like
myself pay for companies
that have the same level of product
market fit and that means
you know i'm not sure how you get a
return on investing in an 11 billion
dollar company
that's probably arguably worth you know
a couple of hundred million you know two
three hundred million would probably be
what it would be as a private company so
this new spac uh revolution that we have
i would just
caution people to really look at who the
promoter is you know if it's chamath
who i obviously have a long-term
relationship with in business we've done
a lot of deals together and work with
friends
you know someone like that is gonna um
put out a certain type of product
and you know given how easy these facts
are we're gonna see a lot of
inventory that might be questionable so
only invest what you can afford to lose
folks there's a lot of
you know red flags with uh nicola and
the product's not out
and i'm not sure that he trevor has
figured out something that elon doesn't
already know over at tesla and so for
him to be deriding the truck
efforts at tesla that he's got a better
mousetrap i find not very credible
um and i'm not sure he's figured out
some secret sauce
you know to go 10x in terms of cost
savings on hydrogen which is kind of
what he was claiming that he's going to
be able to to make this cost 10 times
less
i would rather these companies stay
private and
you know it just feels kind of suspect
to me that doesn't mean he's not going
to pull it off
uh so i wouldn't go as far as saying
it's a thera-nose or a fraud but
uh i would say be very cautious eyes
wide open you're investing pre-product
market fit and that's very dangerous and
you're paying an absurdly
high price so that's just two red flags
right there
that you should know as a retail
investor
yeah jason it's david i mean listen
we've seen the proliferation of spax
everybody's got one at this point and so
i think you can expect that we're going
to see more of these early stage
companies
use it as a vehicle to actually access
the public markets i would point out in
this case steven gursky a very well
uh known auto analyst this was his spack
originally and you know obviously
trevor had pulled in jeff evan from
value act also a very credible
investor but to your point it's going to
be very interesting to watch it's
different than
tesla isn't it i mean he's got an idea
but he isn't necessarily manufacturing
all his own stuff and creating his own
uh technology to a large extent and and
so it does differ although it was enough
to get gm involved at least
to the tune of at least taking two
billion dollars worth of stock
yeah i you know these spacks um are
making me a l
they're they're inspiring on one side
because i do think we want to see retail
investors be able to invest in an uber
or an airbnb
you know five years earlier than maybe
they did so they could see that
appreciation right so
and we would like to double or triple
the number of publicly traded companies
and have a little more choice there and
a little more competition that would be
good
but i think people are going to need to
shift gears a little bit and then
ask themselves you know just because
this looks like tesla doesn't mean it is
tesla and
you know tesla has an engineer at the
lead who is
you know perhaps the most brilliant
engineer of our lifetime i think it's
pretty good uh
argument to be made there that elon is
and i'm obviously close friends with
elon
and you know i've known him since before
you know tesla even existed
and you know he is a great promoter
jason he was a he's a great
man he's produced more cars i mean yeah
and he's produced four cars
and before that i mean it's not gonna be
those
yeah you foreign what elon does is he
sets absurdly hard targets for himself
and then he inspires a team to get there
and i i don't think that
you know at this point in time tesla was
worth 11 billion
and it wasn't you know publicly trading
hands you know elon's entire net worth
was in tesla and he was negative 10
million dollars
uh and he's been pretty public about
living off a loan from a billionaire
friend
um that was giving him two hundred
thousand dollars a year to keep him
alive for that one year when tesla
almost died in the financial crisis so
this was a very different kind of
situation the fact that trevor also took
money off the table that was a red flag
for me so again
lots of red flags and i think it's
important that we all have this
conversation about spacks which are very
exciting
but i'm starting to like it's got that
dot-com feeling
you know dave when like people you know
when you go to the gas station and
the gas attendant was asking you what
stock to buy these smacks have
you know some promoters who i think are
questionable and i think they're looking
to flip companies and i'm
getting phone calls from a lot of people
i've never heard of who haven't been in
business for 10 years
and they've suddenly got us back and
they're asking me for inventory that dot
com that's a little bit strange
i'm here in the righteous brothers i'm
here in the righteous brothers
uh with a remake here jason calacanis
yeah thanks for having me